welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast i am your one and only full-time
permanent host eric trexler but today i
am joined by a special temporary guest
co-host his name is greg knuckles greg
thanks for joining me yeah thanks for
having me on no problem i want to begin
today's episode
by uh extending a great deal of
gratitude uh thanks to everybody who has
been supporting
macro factor during our big launch sale
that is currently going on we launched
on the 16th technically so five days ago
so far it's going fantastic we really
appreciate all the interest all the
support and all the feedback so
if you do happen to check it out for the
free trial uh make sure that you join
the facebook group or the subreddit for
macro factor and let us know how things
are going uh let us know
what kind of features you'd like to see
in the app we really appreciate all your
feedback
um
and yeah so now we want to move on uh
road to the stage
uh road to the stage so uh good news all
around today uh
i
hit a new low for this current diet i
was 240.8 was gonna say this morning it
was not this morning it was in fact this
afternoon when i saw that weight on the
scale uh
my good friend eric woke me up today uh
it did
so
at the crack of 3 p.m
yeah
so in my defense uh until so i went to
bed at like five like 4 30 5 a.m uh and
prior to that this this is not an
exaggeration i
tallied it up before i went to bed i'd
been
answering questions and doing a bit of
customer support for macro factor for 39
hours straight
uh so
ya boy was sleepy uh
so anyway that's that's why it was this
afternoon but yeah 240.8 that's a new
low
uh feeling good my weight trend uh is
below 244
um and i've been below 245 i think for
like six days in a row now so that's a
i would say like a milestone that i've
i've fully fallen beneath hopefully it
will not reclaim that again in the
future
um
and yeah it's it's been good uh this
this has been
a
insane week
all around so uh when i get really busy
one of two things happens with my
appetite and
i want to say ability to stick to a diet
but more like my willingness to stick to
a diet
and that is either that i'm
just like
hungry and craving food all the time
uh or
i have
no appetite and i have to
like remember and force myself to eat
and i think i think it largely comes
down to
how engaged with and how much fun i'm
having with whatever i'm busy doing
um
so
this has been a very
crazy week with the macro factor launch
uh
but it's been very fun
and so
uh yeah it hasn't been it hasn't been
tough to stick to a diet just because
um
you know i'm i'm
very intensely focused on other things
and so like
uh
cravings aren't like slipping into my
brain whereas if i'm very busy and it's
things that i don't particularly want to
be doing
i think i start to
fixate on food
not just food like my brain wonders a
lot and it often
like flits across food as like oh here's
something else to think about because
you're clearly not enjoying the things
that you're actually doing and so like
let's try to find some happy thoughts
and so you know just more distracted
generally and one of the things that my
brain i think tries to distract me with
is thoughts of food
uh so yeah when when i'm very busy doing
things i don't want to do i i find it a
lot harder to stick to a diet
but anyway it's been the good kind of
busy so that's uh
has helped out a lot and things are
going well
awesome congrats
ever closer to the 230s that's big i
think it'll come this week i i think uh
i don't think i'll be consistently
waking up in the 230s next week but i do
i do think i'll see 230 something on the
scale at least once next week which
which feels good yeah
yeah i uh
whenever i'm like really busy and even
just a little bit stressed
my appetite just completely disappears
so if you ever see me uh and it looks
like maybe over the last few weeks i've
lost like seven or eight pounds
it's a cry for help i i need some degree
of
support or attention
uh it's it's like clockwork uh like you
remember when i was trying to close on
my house yeah uh and it was just like a
really stressful time uh
dude i lost like a legitimate nine
pounds in like in a really short span of
time and then once it was all over i
immediately gained exactly nine pounds
back like it was it was crazy um
all right so road to enlightenment
when i first uh started mentioning the
road to enlightenment
and my uh
my path into or journey into
learning more about secular buddhism
i got a lot of messages from people and
i noticed that people are kind of in it
for different things you know some
people are really into secular buddhism
because they want to have like
really big
debates and discussions about
theological concepts or ethical concepts
or things like that
and i noticed other people want to look
at it really rigorously and empirically
and and kind of treat it as like a
branch of neuroscience you know it's
like
there's people who are like oh i'm into
secular buddhism and they're talking
about like fmri all the time you know
so for me personally i was more into
kind of the
day-to-day application you know
that was really what drew me to it and
seeing if i can learn more about these
concepts and apply them can it have a
positive impact on day-to-day life yeah
and i have noticed a lot of that
one of the areas where it's helped out
is dealing with like
you've seen this
just like super vitriolic criticism
where you like read it and you're like
you know it's one thing to like dislike
an article or a podcast or whatever but
like
dude how are you so mad yeah you know
like and so back in the day
i would get those kind of comments and
like my natural response was to like
fully match
the vibes you know like
the
the toxicity the energy level the
general bad vibes i'd be like okay i
guess that's the discussion tone here we
are [ __ ] me no [ __ ] you buddy yeah it's
like it was like that kind of thing um
and i've noticed with like the more i've
gotten into secular buddhism and
practiced more aspects of mindfulness
i'll see something like that take a
couple breaths and say like okay
was this person probably like having a
bad day you know or is there something
else going on behind this
um but that brings me to so a couple
days ago
we put an article on the website it's a
big diet setup guide you know meant to
be like a really comprehensive
synthesis type article where we say like
hey this is from
you know starting from scratch all the
way through the process really
comprehensive review i i wonder if
that'll come up again on this podcast
episode we are getting a little bit of
foreshadowing yeah we are going to
discuss it in detail but real
professional move yeah so one of the
comments that came up on it
was
i'm paraphrasing here for parts of it
but it's basically like listen i already
knew all of this uh very cringe
and and then they said
get a real job
uh and that that
is like right from there right from the
comment
and i was just like
okay that that's fine but um i i do know
who left this comment actually they left
uh kind of like a decoy email
but do you mind if i address them
directly
because i the email didn't fool me it's
your podcast i have uh no ability to
tell you not to say something
yeah so dad listen we can't keep having
this conversation about my career uh
being an assistant blogger is a real job
and i'm just following my dreams so you
know if you and mom want to keep having
this conversation
we can do that but you got to stop
leaving negative reviews and negative
comments on the website okay so that's
taken care of
um
but yeah
path to enlightenment the road to
enlightenment going well
so it's it's funny uh
it's funny you should you should mention
that uh being being judged for your
career choices of being a uh
being an assistant blogger
not an assistant podcast host correct
full-time permanent yeah yeah so this uh
this actually happened to me last week
this is this is completely off script uh
we will get back to feats of strength in
a moment though uh but anyway so uh i
was at i was at the store the other day
and um
the the people bagging groceries were
high schoolers and so
yeah you know if you have adults bagging
your groceries generally they will say
as little to you as possible they'll say
paper plastic and then they'll say like
do you want to round up for salvation
army at the end or like whatever uh
that's about it that is the extent of
the conversation but uh you know
these were high schoolers they were
young they were full of life uh i've
never seen them working there before so
i think it's probably their first week
on the job
and so they they were trying to you know
strike up a conversation with people
coming to check out which um
i understand to some people it might
sound like a very bad scenario i i love
it like i'm
very excited to have little
conversations with as many people who
want to have them throughout the day
um
but yeah so uh
they
just like
asked what what we did for work
and i i have a variety of ways i answer
that question and it largely comes down
to
do i want a follow-up question or not
and i think my most dismissive answer to
that question is i'm a blogger um
because
i don't know
it doesn't sound that interesting i
don't think and
for people who aren't
bloggers i think like
it's
not not understood sufficiently to feel
like you can ask a good follow-up
question except maybe like okay what
subject you blog about and i can say
like yeah strength training style and
fashion yeah
but anyway so i said i'm a blogger but
uh
you know there's still a mask mandate in
raleigh i'm wearing a mask maybe i
didn't enunciate that well either so
they thought i said vlogger
and they they both lit up they're like
oh my god that's awesome i have a buddy
who's a vlogger uh he has like 40 000
subscribers what's your channel we'll
check you out that's so cool i was like
oh no i'm sorry man i'm a blogger with a
b
and they just completely deflated they
went from being so interested to
zero percent interested like what the
[ __ ] dude there's no there's no
video component it's just the b version
not the v version what the [ __ ] man um
the art of the written word is is fully
dead but yeah it was it was so funny
because they uh just completely turned
turned
from being
so excited and invested in learning more
about my vlog to having
zero interest in uh anything blog
related so that i i thought that that
was uh
very very fun and endearing well that's
interesting because if you tell an older
person that you're a blogger they
absolutely don't care yeah and
apparently now younger people also
absolutely don't care so
good good time to be in the blogging
game yeah i i think uh
i think like
um
i think like millennials through like
the younger members of gen x are the
only people who care about blogs which
is fine yeah all right so uh what do we
got here for feature strength
uh yeah so um
let's see several people have reached
out in the last two or three weeks and
uh said hey
feats of strength
generally mostly power lifting and a
little weight lifting you don't talk
about strong man that much uh which that
is a fair criticism and in my defense
just a warning this is going to be a
very weak defense but in my defense uh
this is i think one of the least
important segments in our podcast
so
i do not put that much effort into it
and so you know my uh
my searching is largely relegated to
do i know places where
like new records will be comfortably
aggregated um
and so like
if you go to the powerlifting subreddit
and just search like the top posts from
the past two weeks like most of the most
highly upvoted ones will be recent big
lifts so that's that's very convenient
for powerlifting uh and then
weightlifting i mean like there aren't
that many big weightlifting needs we're
gonna where people are gonna be setting
records and so like
they show up in your feed
and also like i know those sports better
than strongman uh like you know i i
could uh
i could rattle off a lot of the
powerlifting and weightlifting records
but yeah i mean
there's there's so many [ __ ]
strongman records there are so many
lifts and there are so many federations
and whatnot that like
i don't know if someone lifts something
heavy and strong man my first thought is
like
damn that's really cool that's very
impressive my my first thought isn't
like oh is that a new record um
just because like i have no idea because
they do so many things um
so anyway yeah probably don't talk about
strongman and feats of strength as often
as i should uh so uh with that in mind
um this is going to be a strong man
focused feeds of strength segment
because there have been uh strong men
doing very strong things recently okay
we'll call it feats of strong since it's
strong man related well there's
there is one that's not strong man
related okay well anyway so um
let's see nicholas camby uh 105 kilogram
class strongman uh recently set two
separate pressing records at the 2021
clash on the coast uh he broke that
weight classes record for
uh both the uh the block press
um so
i've tried block press before it's
[ __ ] hard uh it's the one where
you're not like holding an implement
they just have like a rectangular box
that you have to get up to your chest
and then
press it's
uh it's very unstable um
relatively hard to control
and
uh
so yeah so that's it's just a tough lift
period uh and so nicholas camby broke
the record uh with uh 141 and a half
kilos or
311.9 pounds which
you know if you're 105 kilos
putting over 300 pounds over your head
any which way you know that's
you're strong if you can do that but
being able to do that with a very
unstable implement like a block press
very very impressive so is this block is
it like the the approximate size of like
a box you'd pick up when you're like
moving like when you're packing up your
house um so i mean there are different
kinds of blocks you could press so if
you go back uh
my first exposure to it was um watching
like reruns of world's strongest man one
of one of the ones that kasmir won they
had a block press uh
and they they were just i think like
probably cement or concrete blocks that
were just hewn
in different
different sizes i think these days it is
standardized and they have loadable
blocks where like you know the whole
thing when it's put together is firmly
constructed but you can change the
weight and so it's a little bit more
standardized but i'd say it's
like maybe shoulder width or slightly
wider and maybe like
six eight inches tall okay thereabouts
um
and and so yeah it's i mean it's an
awkward implement yeah um
so anyway at uh at the same event he
also broke the log press world record um
with
187 kilograms or 412 pounds uh i i think
that broke uh rob kearney's old world
record if memory serves um so yeah two
pressing records at the same event very
impressive stuff
uh
moving to kind of more old-school-ish
uh strong-man stuff back in august
uh lawrence chalet
broke the uh denny stone cary world
record so
the denny stones are two
big ol rocks over in scotland i believe
it's either scotland or ireland i'm
almost positive at scotland anyway
they're two big old rocks one of them
weighs a little bit over 300 pounds one
of them weighs a little bit over 400
pounds uh the legend goes uh donald
denny uh
way back in the day picked them up and
carried them across a bridge um and then
they just kind of like
stayed there for for anyone else who
wanted to to match the feet of donald
um
and so not many people have been able to
fully carry those stones across the
bridge and one of the things that makes
them difficult well two two things that
make it very difficult to do so
is uh one
as i just alluded to the stones are
different sizes uh one of them's about
100 pounds heavier than the other one
and so
like i don't know if you've ever done
like heavy farmers walks but like
accidentally misloaded the two handles
so one of them's heavier than the other
you pick it up you try to walk with it
you know how weird that feels so you're
already dealing with uh
the fact that they're
loaded different amounts
and then also um
so i should have explained this better
you're not like picking one up in each
arm or anything like that
there are handles attached to them that
is is what you pick them up with but the
handles are rings like ring-shaped
handles uh and so my understanding is
that like they are hard to get a good
grip on and they cut into your hands in
like weird and uncomfortable ways uh so
anyway um yeah being able to pick those
suckers up i think only a little bit
over a hundred people have ever done it
um and
i think only like eight or ten people
have ever
carried them the full distance that uh
donald denny was claimed to have done in
record
uh or in in legend i should say um
but anyway so until uh until chalet the
record for the furthest dinny stone
carry uh was held by brian shaw and he
carried them
a little bit over
13 feet i believe for um
or maybe a little bit over 10 feet i
should have taken that that note
anyway the record was previously held by
brian shaw
and he actually set the record while
filming that show that used to be on the
history channel the strongest men in
history
um so brian shaw previously had the
record and uh lauren chalet uh carried
the denny stones 14 feet 10 inches or a
little bit over four and a half meters
to break that record recently which
is
insanely impressive one other thing just
to add about the denny stones before
moving on uh there have been
a few women who have lifted the denny
stones
but the the history of women lifting the
denny stones
is uh
i'd say very very
uneven
that's not a good way to describe it let
me let me uh just be explicit about it
jan todd so i'm sure you know about jan
todd
a lot of our listeners probably don't uh
she's one of the the mothers of
like serious strength sports and like
strength feats uh for women um
like huge pioneer in the area
uh but so she left she she became the
first woman to lift the denny stones in
1979
and i don't think uh
any women lifted the denny stones again
until 2018. wow and so uh
since then there have been a few other
women who've lifted the denny stones but
uh jan todd just just way ahead of the
field on that one um if you don't know
about jan todd you should look her up
very very uh
just impressive athlete in virtually
anything where being strong helps you
out
yeah and and just way way ahead of her
time and they've got a cool they had a
cool thing going down there at uh
university of texas in austin it was
like uh a whole academic program
dedicated to
uh the history of you know physical
culture and strength sport i believe
she's still heading that uh
yeah department i think you're right
yeah
um
so yeah both uh
both an insane athlete and a scholar yep
uh okay so the last uh strong man
related one and if anyone listening to
this does follow strong man you knew i
was gonna mention this uh iron bibby
broke the log press world record uh for
the super heavyweight division
229 kilos which i think is 506 pounds
thereabouts um
not too much more to add to that that's
a ton of weight to put over your head on
a [ __ ] log
uh
the thing so
the thing that is most impressive to me
about
log press world records
is how comfortably they seem to clean it
um like i i've i've actually done a fair
bit of log pressing that's
i i think of the strong man
movements i've dabbled with my my
favorite is probably like 18 inch
deadlift just because you load it up you
pick up something really heavy and i
really like partial deadlifts second
favorite is probably log press uh
there's just something very satisfying
about it but i always find the clean
very
challenging so like
anyone who can
who can log clean
anywhere close to 500 pounds is just
wild to me um
but yeah so uh new record 229 kilograms
seems to be very close to uh
you know moving past the 230 kilo
milestone so uh congrats to him there's
a video of this on the official
strongman youtube channel uh you should
check it out so the the video is like
five minutes long and like
30 seconds of that is the lift uh and
then the rest of it is you know just
like
kind of like the celebration the the guy
on the mic hyping him up and then like a
little interview um he just comes across
as as a very humble and genuine guy as
well so
uh a very likable champion so uh
congratulations to him
and then the final feat of strength uh
not keeping this 100
strong man uh focused
someone shared this in the stronger by
science facebook group um
it is and i think this is the youngest
uh
youngest person to be inducted into the
feats of strength segment on the
stronger by science podcast uh
a young girl named rory van olft i i
believe that's how you would pronounce
her name i don't see how you'd pronounce
it any other way rory van olft i think
she's like either eight or nine years
old uh there's a video of her
nope turn off the volume uh there was a
video of her uh deadlifting 90 kilos at
a body weight of 30 kilos whoa
that's like 66 pounds dead lifting right
at 200. uh she is using straps but also
like
young children have small hands
uh standard barbell is therefore
probably too large for their hands to
actually
actually lift heavy that's it's like
deadlifting on a on a fat bar for an
adult uh so yeah uh very very impressive
uh you know we've talked about this on
the podcast before strength to body
weight ratios aren't everything um it's
easier to have a high one if you simply
don't weigh very much allometric scaling
etc um
but yeah like who gives a [ __ ] this is
an eight-year-old girl pulling almost
200 pounds
good job
that's crazy
yeah
that's really impressive so uh yeah uh
congratulations to her she uh
i mean
they're they're
after this video was shared in the
stronger by science group uh checked out
her instagram she does all kinds of
strong stuff she's
far stronger than any eight-year-old uh
has any right to be so uh
congratulations to her and and i
certainly wish her all the best nice
all right so we've got a new segment
here uh we've got a segment that we're
calling tech support uh obviously this
is new because uh we've only recently
dabbled in the world of technology and
phone apps and supporting people and
supporting people yeah that's never been
our strong suit
but uh basically what we're going to
talk about here is some of the biggest
questions and comments about the app so
far going to try to keep it short but
these are questions and comments that
came up enough that we felt like it
would be worth addressing and they are
uh informative outside the realm of just
the app these are things that are still
usable pieces of information even if
you're not using a diet tracking app
yeah so the first thing some of them are
the first thing we do want to mention so
if you go to
strongerbyscience.com
macro factor that's the page that
contains a ton of information about the
macro factor diet app and there's a huge
grid
that compares and contrasts uh various
features of several different diet apps
so basically for the consumer who wants
to look at this grid and compare and
contrast all their different options for
uh for different diet apps that's what
what the purpose is and we did uh omit a
check that we went in and corrected so
uh one of the the features or uh kind of
selling points for the different apps is
whether or not you use a food database
that is verified by registered
dietitians
and so with the rp diet app we did not
give them the check mark for that
we were unaware that they used an rd
verified food database so
they were very cool uh they just sent us
a quick message someone from the rp died
app and said hey just so you know we
don't like put it front and center we
don't advertise it we understand why you
didn't know that we use this database
but we do so we appreciate them for just
being cool and letting us know and of
course we
had no interest or intention of
misrepresenting that so we went back in
updated the grid and we're going to
continue to update the grid you know uh
if if there's anything that we missed of
course we'll always update that promptly
and there's new exclusive features we
add that we can yeah add lines to the
grid
cooler yeah if we add something or if
other diet apps add stuff you know we're
going to continue to update that because
diet apps are not totally uh you know
static you know different apps can add
different features as they go and so if
we get to the point where we have to
start filling in all these all these
different checks then for the consumer
that's a huge win yeah there's a lot of
features out there
it's going to be a pain in the ass for
lindsay to keep that updated but it's uh
going to be good for you the consumer
yeah
okay so now getting to a couple things
uh
that have come up one of the things that
comes up a lot is people have asked
within the macro factor app
we use the calorie information that
comes from the food database which
corresponds with what you would
typically see on the food label right so
that's the calorie number that we pull
in
and users have noticed
if i assume four calories per gram for
carbohydrate and for protein
and if i assume nine calories per gram
for fat
my macro totals if i do some
multiplication don't give me the same
calorie number that i'm seeing for the
total calories
and they're wondering if it's a rounding
error if there's a mistake if the food
labels are listing perfectly accurate
macros but just kind of putting their
thumb on the scale and under counting
their calories there's been a lot of
confusion and a lot of people saying hey
give me the correct calories which is
by multiplying these macros well and
also just people coming from other diet
apps and they say like hey
uh
we're we're liking my macro factor so
far but the previous app i used had this
feature and you don't so why don't you
have it
yeah this is
uh one of the areas where we did like
the previous app we used more so you
know what gives yeah and so when we went
in to the stages of development you know
this isn't something that we totally
overlooked and we're like oh god uh why
didn't we think of that uh the decision
to not go that route with multiplying
the macro totals by those standard
numbers
was intentional and just for a little
bit of context there are a lot of
different ways that you could represent
the calorie content of a food so you
could go purely based on
gross calories from bond calorimetry
you could do gross calories based on
based on the specific heats of
combustion for the different macros so
you could add up the macros and multiply
the fat by 9.4 calories per gram
carbohydrate by 4.1
and protein by 5.65 that's another
method or you could use the
metabolizable calorie uh like general
factors four four and nine
um or you could just take the calorie
number straight from the label you know
there's a lot of different ways to do
this and in fact you could get even more
granular if you wanted to so
not every protein has exactly the same
amount of calories per gram you know if
you look look at the
individual amino acids you could really
drive yourself crazy trying to go in and
make these perfectly tailored uh numbers
yeah i i think that is something that um
i think that's something that people
aren't aware of unless they've looked
into the history of where those four
four and nine figures came from
uh
that was a
it was a somewhat controversial move at
the time because
uh before
like
nutrition
labels were
really a thing or at least nearly as
standardized as they are now
um
i people had kind of a better
understanding that um
the metabolizable energy that you can
get from
like different
sources of different nutrients varied
slightly so you know if you if you go
back to the research where those four
four and nine numbers derived from uh
i mean what what they essentially did is
is they look to see how much energy was
derived from
a wide variety of protein sources a wide
variety of carbohydrate sources a wide
variety of fat sources uh and basically
just listed like okay here's
for each individual like nutrient that
falls under these umbrellas you know
here's how many calories per gram there
there was uh and the reason they settled
on four four and nine is that for carbs
it never
really dv it just it generally didn't
deviate that far from four for proteins
it generally didn't deviate that far
from four and for fats it generally
didn't deviate that far from nine but
like there are and i don't have them
right off the top of my head but like
there are proteins that have like
you know 3.3 uh kilocalories per gram
and there are some that have like maybe
slightly more than five kilocalories per
gram but
within the broad world of proteins most
of them are close enough to four that if
you're just saying like okay how many
calories per gram do you get from
protein it's probably about four
but the the four four and nine numbers
are
uh
inexact approximations for any
particular discrete carbohydrate protein
or fat source those those are just
they're close enough for all of them but
uh
it's not like a perfectly precise number
for any of them
yeah so you know a reality here when
you're talking about tracking macros and
tracking calories is that whatever
method you use for your calorie
quantification some degree of
imprecision
is going to be unavoidable i mean that
you are signing up for that when you get
into the game of counting calories and
counting macros so uh then it just comes
down to different pros and cons of
different approaches i think one of the
areas where you see some of the bigger
discrepancies usually the events that
cause someone to ask us about it
is foods that have really high fiber
content and where the uh you know fiber
is going to be listed as carbohydrate on
the label uh but in many cases the type
of fiber you know the the energy the
metabolizable energy content of it is
totally known and it's far below four
calories per gram and so in a lot of
those instances you'll see a food where
you know the uh the calculated calorie
total based on just that basic uh macro
calculation
is far higher than the calorie number
listed on the food label and what is
happening there is that the food label
is accounting for the fact that
those grams of fiber are not going to be
contributing 4 calories per gram
and so in that case
it's a scenario where you get
discrepancies when you look at your
macro totals and you look at your
calorie total but in that instance i i
think you can make a very strong
argument that
it's good that that you have that
mismatch the the calorie uh number that
is being counted is more reflective of
the energy your body is going to be
absorbing from that meal so
uh i believe we are gonna introduce that
feature down the line or we're at least
considering it where you can opt in to
uh having your calories counted that way
yeah we're
it's in discussion
we'll probably add it eventually it
probably won't be anytime particularly
soon
and we're doing it begrudgingly for the
record yeah yeah um
you know so i i think there are um
i don't want to get off off track yet uh
yeah so they're they're
we probably will add it eventually there
are
uh other features we have in mind more
imminently that we think will
uh
be more valuable that we're we're
prioritizing for development so yeah we
we might add that at some point but it
probably won't be any time particularly
soon yeah
okay moving on to the next one uh no not
yet so i did have two things i wanted to
add okay um
so i i think that within within the
fitness world uh i think the reason that
there
is the desire to track calories as just
like the sum of the macros and just
multiplying them up i i think that that
exists for two reasons one is
uh i think
everyone has probably seen like a
supplement label that that was just
grossly inaccurate at some point so uh
pretty pretty famously like a few years
ago when like everyone was very mad
about bcaas uh there were a lot of
images going around of like
labels of branch chain amino acid
products that on the label it says like
per serving 10 grams of protein zero
calories and like obviously that's
[ __ ] wrong like that's not even close
to accurate yeah um
and and like there are there are other
supplements where
like the if if the macronutrient
information on the sub on the supplement
label is correct the calories must be
wrong um
so like that it's not that uh
so in a situation like that's just
summing up the calories from the macros
would probably be
more correct but
that's kind of just a problem with
supplements
and it's more an issue with
that supplement supplement the way it's
being labeled correct so than an issue
of using calories from food labels right
so that that is not an issue with most
supplements uh and it's it's not an
issue
hardly ever for like actual food
products yeah um so yeah i mean if
you're
like the only situation where i could
see you getting a far more accurate
calorie count uh by kind of adding up
and multiplying the macros versus just
using the calorie labels
is if you are getting a relatively large
proportion of your daily calories from
badly mislabeled supplements uh but we
we think or at least hope that that
applies to not very many people
the other thing is i think one of the
reasons why there is
the desire in some
sectors
to account for calories by
adding up and multiplying out the macros
is uh
like in situations like if you've worked
with a nutrition coach for example
um who requires like a very
very extreme degree of adherence
um like you know you need to be within
like 10 grams of each macro and within
like 50 grams of your calorie target or
something like that
and
you know if
if that is an experience that you've had
you will often find that that may not be
possible if you're accounting for
calories and macros independently so the
example you gave earlier was fiber like
if you're eating a fair a fair bit of
fiber uh you know
not even that much if you're eating like
20 grams of fiber per day and like let's
just say all of that is indigestible
that's going to have effectively zero
calorie content but if you're counting
all of that as carbohydrate which the
food labels would
you're going to wind up with a mismatch
of 80 calories between your macro counts
and your calorie counts and so it would
be impossible to be
as adherent as someone is expecting
with your macros and your calories
simultaneously so kind of a way to
resolve that stress uh and i think this
is one of the reasons why some diet
coaches recommend this uh is is they
found that like oh if i want people to
be as adherent as i expect them to be
this is the only way to make their macro
and calorie targets add up
um
but that's kind of
uh
i'm trying to think of a way to describe
this with grace
it's kind of a fiction
i would say like it's it's it's a
workaround to make
that restrictive of a system possible
versus being
a more accurate reflection of reality
yeah um so i think that's
i think people who've come from uh
that type of like very restrictive
nutrition coaching background like if
if you've if you've worked with a coach
like that previously i think um
using that method of calculating
calories just from summing up and
multiplying out the macros i think that
like served a purpose
for you and and more so for your coach
um
at that time but that does
that doesn't mean that it's a more like
actually accurate way to count calories
it was just a way to make that
restrictive nutrition coaching
relationship
possible yeah and you know there's
nothing wrong with saying like hey
you're doing nutrition coaching here are
some macro targets try to keep your
fiber within 30 35 grams a day
that's an easy way to get somebody into
a general calorie range and as long as
you're not
you know being really really ultra
precise within that being super
restrictive no big deal you're basically
dealing with calories without
quantifying them yeah you know as long
as you're keeping that fiber on the
radar um but yeah if if you're trying to
say hey we need to make the calories fit
we need to make the macros fit
everything has to be perfect and there
is no room for error then yeah it gets
really hard to make that work feasibly
yeah
all right ready to move on to the next
one let's do it
okay so uh people have asked why we
don't have
alarms and banners and alerts and all
sorts of
general uh chaos
if they go a little bit over their macro
target for the day so like
uh
if you let's say you were supposed to
have 160 grams of protein
people have asked why it doesn't like
turn red or give you some kind of error
message or alert you if if your protein
goes up to like 161 or 162 or anything
above 160.
um or even like 200. sure like if you
blow past it we don't uh
it doesn't like turn red yeah like we
don't we don't slap on the wrist and say
no bad eat less protein yeah so the
reason's pretty simple um
the targets we give are for guidance you
know we think hey this is probably a
good range for you to be in uh like we
said whenever when it comes to tracking
anything nutritionally uh
any insistence upon upon absolutely
perfect precision is
a bit of
a fiction as you put it i mean it's a
bit of an illusion even if we try to
make it look perfect
realistically it's not
but yeah the targets are for guidance
these are a set of macro targets and a
calorie target that should get you where
you're trying to go in terms of your
goals
and macro factor as an app has a big
emphasis on being adherence neutral so
it doesn't require or expect perfection
in order to keep working effectively you
log what you take in we continue to take
those measurements factor them into a
rolling estimate of total daily energy
expenditure we adjust your calorie
target accordingly uh and so frankly
people are wondering why there aren't a
bunch of alerts and alarms and scary
messages about uh you know the
catastrophic issues of going a little
bit over and the reality is
it's not that bad you know where the app
is gonna continue functioning uh totally
fine
um
going a little bit over a target is not
gonna derail you in any way and we don't
i mean we we market the app as a diet
sidekick like that's what we call it we
want it to be your advisor
and this is something i always remind my
clients of however we will still
occasionally refer to it as a
diet coach which is purely in marketing
copy just purely due to uh our our
desire to rank highly for particular
search terms in the app store
yeah um and to make sure people know
what it actually does yeah yeah
but um you know this is something i
remind my clients of all the time
working one-on-one with people uh
sometimes i'll have a client who's like
man
i really screwed up i went five grams
over on my protein uh and i apologize i
really let you down
and i'm like
dude i i work for you
you know like like the way this is
supposed to work is like you are
the uh you're the president i am your
lowly advisor who gives you
recommendations if you defy my
recommendation i have to deal with that
like you don't you don't owe me an
apology that's not how the the power
balance works here um so it's the same
thing with the app the app is there to
support you
you are not serving the app okay so uh
we don't want to reinforce that type of
thing and
uh have all sorts of negative messaging
if you have a very human level of
imprecision with your tracking yeah or
or i mean so
one of the
one of i think the issues that people
can
run into and one of the one of the
issues that i've dealt with personally
in the past is that um
when you
so like let's say you're tracking in
myfitnesspal uh and you're and you go
over for like carbs or calories or
whatever for the day like when you go
over there will be like a little message
that tells you
you know more or less like hey you
[ __ ] up
um
and so i i think that
and like i realize this is irrational
but like people get into irrational head
spaces when dieting pretty frequently
i i think it's easy to start
conceptualizing your days as successful
versus non-successful and so like you go
over the app says like hey you [ __ ] up
it's like well [ __ ] now i [ __ ] up
today has has been a failure which one
yeah bad vibes and we're trying to avoid
bad vibes but then more importantly you
know once you've already failed like ah
well what's what's the harm and just
having as much fun with this failure as
possible uh as
you know maybe
eating more than you you you were
planning on because like whatever you
already [ __ ] up so like let's just run
with it for the day uh and then try to
get back on
back on the wagon tomorrow um and so i
think like in terms of pursuit of your
goals that can lead to patterns of
thinking that can do far more harm than
good
um
so
with using macro factor like
i i want to make it clear
macro factor was built with you in mind
but very early on it was built with the
five of us in mind
our team like before
alpha start like before alpha testing
started um
you know our thinking was like hey the
five of us track our nutrition what are
things we want to see in a nap and like
how do we want it to behave uh and like
i do not have perfect dietary adherence
i'm in i'm in the middle uh of a very
successful cut but like i'm definitely
not hitting my numbers square on the
head
every day or really even any day uh i'm
generally pretty close for calories and
protein but like fat and carb targets
[ __ ] it i i literally don't even care uh
and you know often i go over on calories
sometimes i go under on protein and like
it's not a big deal
uh but anyway where i was going with
this is um
there's not that negative feedback that
that
leads to the thinking of like okay this
day
now has been a failure and so what i can
do is like you know let's say the app's
telling me my estimated energy
expenditure is
3 300 calories per day that's that's
about what it is right now
uh and i'm aiming to consume like 2 400
calories per day or so uh
if anyone's listening to this and
they're like oh that seems pretty low
it's because i budget like 4 000
calories for every saturday have a big
potluck with friends i eat a lot bump
things down the rest of the week but
anyway so my my goal for the day is like
2 400 um
and
but i know that like my estimated
expenditure is like 3 300 and so i have
i have a range of uh
of six of
actions i can take today that can
uh
lead to success you know maybe not
losing weight at the precise rate that i
want to but that will still result in a
positive outcome so
you know if i'm a little bit under my
calorie targets but not so much that
it's gonna like make me really hungry
like if at the end of the day i see i'm
at like 2200 but i'm like you know what
i'm actually not hungry i'm fine i don't
need to force myself to eat another 200
calories like okay cool that's that's a
successful day
if i get really close to my numbers
obviously successful day pretty good
if i go over uh as long as i'm under my
estimated uh daily energy expenditure
since my goal is to lose weight
i'm basically being prescribed a range
of
you know
numbers that will work like if i'm
above my calorie target but below
my estimated energy expenditure what
that effectively means is like that is
still a range where if i eat eat this
amount i will still lose weight over
time i'll be at maybe at a slightly
slower rate than i would like to so
that's still a successful day like um
and so
yeah ultimately the app is just giving
you information that you can use to make
choices for yourself
uh but we're not gonna judge you for any
of those choices
um
let's see do you
do you want to say the thing about the
inherent assumption in the alerts or do
you want me to uh why don't you do it
yeah okay so
um
this is this i stole this from you on
facebook yeah i i thought you did but if
you
if you had the thought independently as
well i wasn't gonna steal your thunder
yeah so another thing that's like a
little bit [ __ ] up i think about how
um
about how apps
use their alert system to say like hey
you're doing something bad uh it's
it's
i don't want to say always because i
don't know if that's true but it's
almost always when you go over a
particular target so
you know if your goal is to eat like 2
500 calories per day eat 2505 and then
it says like ah you [ __ ] up your goal
was to stay under 2 500 today
[ __ ] you you did bad um
and that's almost exclusively how how it
works there may be an alert in an app
somewhere that says like oh your goal
was to eat 38 grams of fiber today and
you only got 30. so try to eat more
fiber but at least when it comes to to
calories and like macronutrients i i
think the way that they
almost exclusively work
is they don't say you did bad if you
went under they say you did bad if you
went over yeah it's not like you start
logging your food for the next day and
they're like whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a
minute you under eight yesterday yeah
like we have a huge problem yeah exactly
um and so
effectively regardless of what your goal
is
the apps are just trying to force you to
lose weight and and punishing you for
eating more which uh like i i want to
make this clear a lot of the examples
that
we will give and certainly that i will
give when talking about macro factor
will be related to weight loss and that
is for the simple reason that i'm
drawing on my own experiences and i'm
currently trying to lose weight uh but
it's it's not a weight loss app like if
you have a weight loss goal cool we can
help you get there uh if you're trying
to gain weight like
that works the exact same way as losing
weight uh macro factor covers that or
like if you just want to be in
maintenance like maybe you've previously
lost weight but you've struggled with
maintaining uh whatever weight you end
up at and you're you're just like yeah i
want to use an app to help me stay at
maintenance or just purely together
information about myself like i want to
know about what my daily energy
expenditure is i know this app will
calculate that for me
good so like you can use it for many
purposes but i i
again will often talk about it in the
context of weight loss because that's
that's my personal context and
experience
uh but anyway
other other apps regardless of what your
goal is
treat it like you have a weight loss
goal yeah um it's it's bad to go over
your calorie targets it's not equally
bad to stay under
it's just kind of like could you
like the
um
whatever you set as your calorie your
macro targets
it's not
it's not a target it's more like a limit
you know yeah um
you know like
it's it's like a speed limit you get
like over the limit under arrest it's
not like
uh
55 is about what you should aim for on
this road anywhere in the range from
like 40 to 70 will get you where you
need to go
uh
that that's that's how macro factor
treats targets like
it's probably not a great way to
[Music]
play in a highway system but no you know
for just giving
adults
information to inform themselves about
like
well you know based on your goals if you
want to reach them at the weight you say
you want to here's what you should aim
for but you know if you're under if
you're over
like that's fine that's that's a choice
to make um
and
we don't care
yeah we give you a target plus or minus
error and whether it's plus or minus is
uh
immaterial you know you're going to miss
high some days you're going to miss low
some days yeah yeah
all right uh one last thing i want to
briefly mention here
people have asked why we don't use
energy expenditure data from devices
like fitbit so wearable devices that
calculate uh some estimate of total
daily energy expenditure
um
so
it's not like we're taking the cheap way
out or the lazy way out here we have
done everything you would need to do
to integrate that information so we you
can already
link up and synchro synchronize with
different platforms that make that
doable with macro factor but we have
chosen not to bring that energy
expenditure data in because
our algorithm
will by definition work
and one of the issues we have with some
of the wearables is that it can
introduce a magnitude of estimation
error that we're not particularly
comfortable with and can be difficult to
predict on our end because it's not our
technology uh and so
we have uh
a beautiful algorithm and we don't want
to introduce a bunch of error into it uh
is really what it comes down to
some devices obviously are better than
others but you know we covered on the
podcast a million years ago i think we
did uh talking about the uh measurement
error or the estimation error associated
with some of those wearable devices
being
a lot higher than most people would be
comfortable with yeah and the the error
magnitude can be far enough to
really introduce or can be big enough to
introduce uh some big challenges when it
comes to uh total daily energy
expenditure estimations and setting
calorie targets accordingly well there
was there
just to illustrate this there there was
one person uh
who i i don't think they were even
asking about this in the macro factor
subreddit i think this was a question in
the stronger by science subreddit um
someone was basically asking like
uh
so their their question was
how much does like a stress response and
elevated heart rate uh in in the context
of just being stressed about something
how much i think they were watching a
sporting event right yeah not doing it
yeah they were like how much does that
contribute to uh
to elevations in energy expenditure for
example
i was at a football game uh either like
at their college or like the college
that they graduated from something like
that but it was a close game wild fourth
quarter came down to the wire and so
they they were watching it on the edge
of their seat heart rate elevated for
like four hours and like their fitbit
told them that they'd burn like 3000
calories just
swatching a sporting event uh which is
obviously incorrect yeah i i don't feel
like i even have to justify that
statement yeah it got their like
suspense heart rate and was like oh
looks like he went for a jog good for
you yeah
you you've been running at a moderate
pace for the last four hours
congratulations yeah uh but yeah so um
yeah that data uh
at its best is accurate because you know
sometimes it's gonna hit the nail on the
head uh but not infrequently it's going
to be off by really really large margins
um and so like you said it's
using that data now before before we
have an opportunity to
test it and maybe see like
can we use this data to tweak things
around the margin i'm optimistic that we
can uh but they're they're not going to
be particularly large tweaks yeah um
also i think it's worth
never mind that was going to be a
very technical discussion
that i think only like five percent of
people would care about and we've been
talking about this too long anyways
anyway yeah we we don't use that data
yet and it's not because we're being
lazy it just i i think that it would
have the potential eventually to help us
a little bit
but i
don't think it it has the potential to
help us
to a particularly large extent yeah and
like i said uh the integration step is
already taken care of we have the
capacity to bring that data in
if we
determine at a later date like yes
there's something we can do with this
that is usable and it's going to be
really reliable and is going to function
it's going to improve the function of
the app we can do that if we get to that
point but we're just not there yet in
terms of seeing a real tangible benefit
from it
uh okay so greg uh basically the rest of
the show i'm going to talk a little bit
about an article on the stronger by
science website uh before we do that do
you want to do your research review on
the carbohydrate insulin model yeah this
isn't going to be much of a research
review because it's not really even
talking about research uh it is talking
about a paper that was published in a
peer-reviewed journal but it's it's not
original research so uh the narrative
review right yeah sure so i i just have
like one little point to make about it
so there was a
paper recently published titled the the
carbohydrate insulin model colon a
physiological perspective on the obesity
epidemic
by
david ludwig and a bunch of other
authors uh some some people on this list
that uh folks listening to the podcast
may be
aware of are gary taubes jeff folek
walter willett
uh cara ebeling
um so yeah
this is
the only reason i'm mentioning this is
that uh
a lot of people
asked us about it
um and just like oh what do you think
about this like is there
more and more evidence to support the
carbohydrate insulin model of obesity
and i think one of the reasons that
people were particularly interested
about it is this this
perspectives paper was published in the
american journal of clinical nutrition
which is a
very prestigious journal so it kind of
um
implies that this discussion has
an elevated degree of legitimacy and
like institutional heft behind it um
since they were able to get get the
paper in this particular journal
but you look like you're about to say
something no i was going to make a quip
about um
you know prestige is cool if that if
you're into that kind of thing with
journals but
yeah i yeah i don't think it's worth
much but uh yeah other people do and
that's fine i can i can respect their
opinion um
but yeah so
i
the the only thing i really want to say
about this paper is that
i feel like they are
straw manning the energy balance model
and i think
the
alternative model that they're proposing
i i think that they're uh
they're stating or implying
that it differs from the energy balance
model
um
to to a degree that is not
justifiable basically i i don't know i'm
trying to be
too fair and circumspect with this
criticism the alternate model they
proposed is entirely
consistent with the energy balance model
um
and so i feel like they kind of had to
straw man the energy balance model a
little bit just to
present their model as something that
was in opposition to it
so
when we were asked about this on
facebook here was
um
the first thing i said and i'm going to
be reading this mostly because the
majority of this content uh
is direct quotes from the paper and i
want to make sure i get those quotes
right sure
so uh let's see
here's how they wrap up uh their intro
for the quote energy balance model in
the paper so that what comes next is a
direct quote from the paper uh how
they're describing the energy balance
model and i think that
what is about to come is a accurate
description of the en of the energy
balance model um
and they they strong in it a little bit
uh later and actually i'm not even gonna
get into that like th this what i'm
about to say is really my my key point
okay so here's the quote from the paper
importantly the energy balance model
considers all calories metabolically
alike for practical purposes thus
specific foods or diets may produce
variable amounts of weight gain or loss
but virtually only through energy intake
related to hunger satiation satiety
hedonic effects or passive over
consumption
dietary treatment focuses on behavioral
strategies to help people reduce energy
intake especially of the energy dense
tasty processed foods thought to drive a
positive energy balance to maintain
adverse effect or to manage adverse
effects eg hunger okay so that's their
description of the energy balance model
uh in quote by the way that's their
description of the energy balance model
so
uh
within how they're describing the energy
balance model particular foods may drive
weight gain uh
through effects related to hunger
satiation satiety hedonic effects or
passive over consumption
uh so that that's how they're setting up
their nemesis the energy balance model
okay so um let's see so then i go on to
say uh
so the energy balance the energy balance
model which they're arguing against
posits that specific foods or diets
contribute to obesity via increased
energy intake related to hunger
satiation satiety hedonic effects etc
good to see that what i just rift about
is the same as what i said previously
that's consistency for you baby okay
then their entire discussion of the
carbohydrate insulin model
is a discussion of why they think foods
with high glycemic loads increase energy
intake largely due to increases in
hunger and cravings
than parentheses and cravings implies
hedonic effects in my opinion
this paragraph is a pretty good
distillation of their proposed mechanism
of action okay so going back to the
paper direct quote the rapid absorption
of glucose after a consumption of a high
glycemic load meal increases insulin
secretion
suppresses glucagon secretion and
elicits a glucose dependent is
insulinotropic polypeptide dominant in
[ __ ] response this highly anabolic
state for the first few hours after
eating promotes avid uptake of glucose
into muscle liver ab ad
muscle liver and adipose and stimulates
lipogenesis in liver and adipose three
hours after eating most of the nutrients
from a high glycemic load meal have been
absorbed from the digestive tract
however the persistent anabolic actions
from the hormonal response slow the
shift from uptake to release of glucose
in liver and fatty acids in adipocytes
consequently total metabolic fuel
concentrations in the blood from glucose
non-esterified fatty acids and ketones
decreases rapidly in the late
postprandial phase possibly to
concentrations below that of the fasting
state the brain perceives this signal as
indicating that critical tissues eg the
liver are deprived of energy a state of
cellular semi-starvation as it has been
termed and may respond to the metabolic
challenge with a counter regulatory
hormone response
simultaneously uh
dang it lost my place simultaneously
hunger and cravings for high glycemic
load foods i.e those that rapidly raise
blood glucose increase setting the stage
for a vicious cycle energy expenditure
may also decline related to decreased
fuel availability hormonal eg thyroid
effects on metabolic pathways and
thermogen
and thermogenic tissue or compensatory
adaptations eg and autonomic tone
affecting the postprandial state resting
energy expenditure muscle efficiency or
physical activity level so just to break
that down so i i wanted to read those
quotes in full just to make sure that i
wasn't misrepresenting what they were
saying
the model that they're proposing
is essentially when you eat foods with a
high glycemic load
you're going to get
like rapid
disposal of glucose into tissues to
due to a high insulin response and gip
response which is then going to decrease
blood glucose levels
to in a way that your brain perceives as
um
like
what they term cellular semi starvation
and then that is then going to cause you
to
consume more high glycemic load foods to
basically compensate
uh get your blood glucose levels back up
um
you know tell your brain that your body
is in fact nourished and that basically
kicks off a vicious cycle so
i think it's worth noting
that
what they are proposing is
completely combat compatible with the
energy balance model that they seem to
be arguing against they're essentially
arguing that high glycemic load foods
kick off this positive feedback loop
which ultimately leads to greater energy
intake
and therefore
weight
and and fat accumulation like that that
is the model that they're proposing
um
and and
the
like
their reasoning is completely consistent
with how they state the energy balance
model works they're basically saying
that you you get these blood glucose
drops after a high glycemic load mood
or after a high glycemic load meal which
leads to greater hunger lower satiation
lower satiety
uh
and cravings eg hedonic effects
and that leads you to eat more high
glycemic load foods that's exactly how
how they described the energy balance
model as working like
these things occur you eat more you gain
weight um
the the little sleight of hand they do
is essentially say like oh well the
energy balance model
proposes that kind of the genesis of all
of this is you eat more you gain weight
what we're saying is you gain weight
and that induces cravings for high
glycemic load foods and then you eat
more it's a chicken and egg thing
they're saying that the
which comes first in chicken and egg i
think that's the whole point you don't
know yeah i'm just gonna say it's the
chicken they're saying the chicken is
you eat more we're saying the chicken is
you gain weight ultimately you get to
the same place but we're saying that the
the
inciting incident is slightly different
and i
i find that incredible
because i think
i think everyone else except maybe the
authors of this paper
are aware that
basically everything in biology runs in
feedback loops
and so like that's kind of the whole
point of the chicken and egg metaphor
you don't know which one came first and
it doesn't [ __ ] matter which one came
first like if they're saying like oh you
you gained more weight and that's what
is
causing you to eat more well then that
begs the question like
well how how did you gain more weight
then buddy like how did how did that
occur like at some point in the process
like they're they're not arguing against
um positive energy balance being the the
cause of weight gain ultimately and so
like
you know if they're saying the inciting
incident is gaining weight that implies
that someone
previously had eaten more so like
i don't know man i i read the paper and
by the end of it
like
i think that there are things about
their interpretation of some mechanisms
that i would quibble with but ultimately
i i was just wondering like
why did you write this because
if if they didn't write it
if they didn't write it as a
framing of carbohydrate insulin model
versus energy balance model i think it
could have actually been a pretty
valuable paper
if if they were saying like you know
people have positive energy balance over
time that's one of the things
contributing to the obesity epidemic
here is a potential mechanism
that could be contributing to positive
energy balance in some populations over
time um
like that would have been a perfectly
fair framing of the evidence that they
presented
uh and i think i think it would have uh
been a a challenging and
thought-provoking and valuable paper but
their their choice to frame it as like
hey here's this thing that's different
than the energy balance model and and
now these two things are in conflict i
think in the conclusion they refer to it
as a paradigm clash
uh
like by the time i got there and saw the
phrase paradigm clash i was ready to
pull my hair out because
i was just thinking like everything
you've described to this point
the the uh
like causal chain of events that you're
proposing that contributes to all of
these things literally all of it is
consistent with the energy balance model
so it's
um
yeah i wouldn't even necessarily say
it's a bad paper it's just a deeply
frustrated paper or frustrating paper
because
it seems like either they don't fully
understand what they're arguing against
which
i feel like they have to like there are
some smart guys on that paper and
they've been having this argument for
like 15 years right so
it feels like either they don't
understand what they're arguing against
or they're
willfully misrepresenting it
for the purpose of
getting press
and getting their paper out there and
getting citations which
i'm not going to claim that that's what
they're doing because i don't know
what's in their hearts but boy that's
what it feels like
yeah i mean i'm yeah it's not that it's
not that bad of a paper ultimately
it's just deeply frustrating
yeah well i gotta admit i didn't read it
uh so i'm not participating in the
frustration because you really didn't
miss anything i mean if you were
if you were kind of staying up to date
with this whole
clash going back you know to the
i mean like i said it's probably been 10
or 15 years going
where this has been kind of accelerating
and going back and forth
at a certain point you would just be
like man these goal posts keep moving um
things keep getting reframed and
redefined and no so i'm
i'm sorry i'm sorry to cut you off but
no so that that is actually one of the
key points i meant to make uh
that i i forgot to because i got a
little worked up um yeah so i think that
one of the noteworthy things about this
paper and and one of the reasons i that
i didn't completely hate it um
is the fact that like you're saying the
shifting goal posts
not all of these authors i don't want to
paint with too broad of a brush there
were 17 authors on on this paper but
several of the authors on this paper
in the not too distant past
have argued for
stronger versions of the carbohydrate
insulin model of obesity that
were not consistent with the evidence
of the energy balance model
so the fact that the goal posts have
shifted so far that their current
iteration of the carbohydrate insulin
model of obesity is 100
fully consistent with the energy balance
model to the point that now they're just
kind of like
i don't know quibbling about which came
first the chicken or the egg
i think that uh
it is really great vindication for
people several years ago saying like oh
yeah your arguments are [ __ ] weak for
like the more
like the harder versions of the
carbohydrate insulin model because
they've
they have come
they've shifted the goal posts all the
way to the point that their current goal
posts are
basically the same goal posts as the
energy balance model you kick a ball
through one you kick a ball through both
um
and so if anything
i don't know this paper might be the
white flag like they they might be
saying like yeah we
we lost to this one we want to make we
want to be able to hold on to our pride
and still say that these two models are
different and that we're still right but
we have to recognize that the evidence
that
it doesn't ultimately come down to
energy balance like
we we have to take the l on that one
right yeah and i mean
i remember following this back in the
day
and you would see all of these
discussions saying like okay so
with the more um
uh
with the really aggressive versions of
the whole uh carbohydrate insulin model
you'd say okay so
if that is true then we should observe
the following and then there's a
randomized controlled trial and we do
not observe kind of the intuitive
outcome we would expect if that model
was fully supported
and you do that again and again and
again and then you do a couple meta
analyses and you keep finding like dude
the interventions that you're implying
with this model do not seem to be
outperforming other interventions and it
looks like the energy balance model
is doing a pretty good job holding up
now there are of course major challenges
with turning the conceptual uh aspect of
the energy balance model into
really effective and actionable
interventions to change body weight
that's where things get extremely
challenging you start talking about
how do we put together really good
interventions to
uh to support
really big behavior change so i'm not
saying you know oh weight loss is really
as simple as this and there's nothing
else to it it's conceptually it fits
very well within the energy balance
model paradigm i think the biggest
hurdle the biggest challenge moving
forward is taking that energy balance
model you know the the
the the conceptual
knowledge that comes from it and saying
okay now how do we make this more
actionable so that we can help people
well yeah so that's exactly what i was
saying about how
the paper could have been framed in that
way and it could have been pretty
valuable like
if they wanted to argue like
okay ultimately it comes down to energy
balance and we believe for these reasons
that if you eat a generally balanced
diet but uh strongly curtail high
glycemic load meals
that behavioral change which you know
may may be more tolerable to a lot of
people than asking them to exercise way
more like asking them to make
cut out an entire uh category of
food like an entire macronutrient like
we're not saying you have to go
no carb or even low carb we're just
saying like yeah they're really high
glycemic load stuff cut down on that
like okay
that might be a
a tolerable behavior change that people
can stick to and so
you know we're proposing that this is
something within the energy balance
model that could make a dent in this
thing
like
at that point you could then quibble
about like maybe some of the research
they cite maybe some of the
interpretations of it and ultimately i'm
not really even that interested in that
conversation but
that would be a useful jumping off point
to have a conversation um so yeah i
think
like i said before i think if they would
have framed their paper that way it
would have been it would have been a
good interesting paper um
that they could have uh
inspired collaborative discussion
related to how you can
you know interpret some of their
arguments and and maybe use that to
um
help people
get where they want to go instead of
just saying like
this is a grand battle of ideas it's a
paradigm clash like blah blah blah yeah
i don't know it's
it's very it's very silly it's very
silly i agree
all right so uh
moving on
yeah
we're kind of behind the timeline we
were we were aiming for a little bit
behind the timeline yeah that's okay so
let's let's dive right in okay so um
as i mentioned earlier in the episode uh
we released an article
yesterday maybe
the the days are really blended together
we did drop it yesterday we dropped it
three days ago as of the time you'll be
listening to this yeah so uh the article
the short title
is the definitive diet setup guide and
so the whole purpose here was to help
somebody you know just coming into it
starting from scratch and saying let's
put together a diet
for a particular goal whether it would
be weight gain weight loss weight
maintenance whatever the case may be
i don't want to be too repetitive here
because we have talked about some
aspects of what this article provides
but what i would hope you know
i i do expect that a lot of people will
look at this and say a lot of this
information i knew previously but what i
think people will get out of this is a
couple things so first of all if you
know somebody who's going to start a
diet who hasn't been into nutrition as
long as you have i'd like to think this
is a good resource you can send them
that kind of boils it down to pretty
simple things and says hey here's how
you might start from scratch and put a
diet together i also think
it offers some
slightly refined recommendations when it
comes to
various aspects of dying dieting
particularly macronutrient targets so i
want to get into how the macronutrient
guidelines differ
from some of the more common ones that
we see elsewhere
so
i want to talk about our activity
factors because that was the one thing
that i contributed and i feel good about
it we're going to so if you look at the
article uh it's kind of in three parts
so it talks a little bit about
background information then it talks
more about putting that into practice
putting some numbers on it and then it
also talks about how to adjust the diet
as you go because you're not going to
set one diet and ride that out for the
rest of your life you're going to have
to make
you know continuous adjustments as you
go because as we know whether we're
talking about over feeding or under
feeding the body does tend to adjust
okay so it starts out uh talking about
some of those metabolic rate equations
we mentioned previously uh i think the
revised harris benedict equation is
great if you're a non-lifter uh if
you're a lifter i think the cunningham
equation from 1980 is really excellent
so that can give you an idea of your
total daily energy expenditure or your
resting metabolic rate i should say
um if you
had absolutely no idea going into it so
if you hadn't been tracking and you had
no idea what your your maintenance
calories look like you could use that to
get your resting energy expenditure and
then we convert that to a total daily
energy expenditure estimate
using
the macro factor correction factors that
greg is so proud of and the one uh
very intuitive obvious but completely
innovative thing we did here
is we finally separated out general
activity from structured exercise
activity uh because
the way it was done previously there if
you were someone who trained a lot but
were otherwise sedentary there was no
help for you there um if you were
somebody who was generally quite active
but didn't do any exercise at all it was
still kind of hard to tell where you
would fall in that so what we do is we
set up
your general activity correction factor
if you're not very active in terms of
general non-exercise activity uh it's a
1.2 if you're moderately active 1.4 if
you're highly active that'd be 1.6
and then the adjustment for exercise
activity is additive
and so there's a whole grid in the
article that kind of talks through what
value you would choose based on your
general activity level your exercise
activity level based on number of
training sessions per week
add those up multiply by the resting
energy expenditure estimate now you've
got a pretty good estimate for total
daily energy expenditure
then what we do
is we offer up some targets for if you
have a weight loss goal
a maintenance goal
or a weight gain goal
what kind of targets you'd be looking
for in terms of
monitoring changes in body weight over
time so obviously with maintenance you
would expect that body weight is going
to stay pretty stable uh we we give some
guidelines you know so if you're going
to be cutting aggressively you might be
losing more than one percent of body
weight per week moderate cut is going to
be lower than that you know 0.25 to 1 of
body weight per week we do the same
thing when it comes to bulking uh so a
moderate bulk talking about gaining 0.1
to 0.25
percent of body weight per week
aggressive bulk over 0.25 percent of
body weight per week and those are a
little bit on the conservative side so
one of the things macro factor does is
it tweaks your recommendation in terms
of the ranges for rate of weight gain
based on your experience level as a
lifter so if you're a total beginner and
you're about to really ride that wave of
some really sick beginner gains
we would say you know what yeah it's
okay if we bump that a little
comfortably above 0.25 percent of body
weight per week because you're gonna be
putting on some mass over the next few
months you know so those these uh ranges
are not perfect for everybody but
what we want to do is make sure that
people are bulking we've all been there
uh i know both of us have greg where you
do your first bulk you way overestimate
how rapidly you can gain muscle and the
magnitude of muscle you can gain and
then you look back at it you say dude
why did i do this like i should have
gone slower i would have been happier
with the result so we do kind of err on
the conservative side there but you you
get freedom within the app to adjust
that upward if you'd like
so
that's how we kind of go through the
article in terms of figuring out okay
what's my total daily energy expenditure
in order to
uh achieve a particu particular
physique goal you know how rapidly
should i be gaining or losing body
weight and then of course you're going
to be adjusting your calorie target as
you go based on how your body weight is
responding
one of the things i'm really proud of
with this article
is that we didn't give macronutrient
target
recommendations uh in the way that it's
typically done okay so
a lot of times with protein targets it's
going to be a very simple uh you know
grams per kilogram of total body mass
and the same thing goes when it comes to
setting a lower limit for fat intake a
lot of times people say
0.5 6.7 grams per kilogram of total body
mass
and to be clear the reason why uh most
protein recommendations are just grams
per kilogram or grams per pound of just
total body mass uh is that that's how
it's quantified generally in the
research so you know if you're a
evidence-based guy or gal uh and you're
saying like well okay like what are what
are some research backed numbers you you
are probably going to come across
numbers in grams per pound or grams per
kilogram so that's a very
both understandable and justifiable uh
way to give recommendations and i mean
i've i've certainly done so uh
frequently in the past and and probably
uh from time to time will continue to do
so in the future yeah there are contexts
where it makes sense no question i've
done it before um
but the challenge with creating a diet
app is uh you know like you said in
research they'll say oh grams per
kilogram we'll look at previous research
use that number put it in here we're
good to go yeah they don't have to deal
with the dilemma of people of wildly
different body sizes
using an application to give a
recommendation correct right i i was
teeing you up for that yeah so you know
a classic alley-oop yeah if you consider
a hypothetical scenario right so let's
say a person 350 pounds uh i'm not going
to do kilograms because i believe in
freedom units and that's my right
and i'm not good at the calculation like
you are uh but a 350 pound person who
has a weight loss goal it's like 160
keys yeah so
i struggle when we take those flat
recommendations based on body weight a
lot of people say oh weight loss you
know give them like 2.2 grams per
kilogram of protein
i struggle to buy the concept that that
individual necessarily needs 350 grams
of protein to support their goal same
thing goes even if you set fat at the
absolute lower level that a lot of
people recommend we're still talking
about like their absolute bare minimum
at the start of this diet is going to be
716 calories coming straight from fat
alone
so just from the fat and the protein
i mean we're talking about a really
substantial calorie intake that's going
to leave them in a spot where they
probably don't need necessarily all of
that fat intake and all of that protein
intake and now their hands are tied when
it comes to getting some allocation of
calories from carbohydrate you know
they're kind of forced into a particular
approach that people who like the carb
insulin model i'm sure would be very
happy about yeah um yeah like like
functionally if you say like
okay we need uh some level of fat intake
just to make sure you're you're healthy
and safe and can produce hormones uh and
we're gonna prioritize protein intake
past that make sure you can uh
you know get big stay big not lose a ton
of muscle
functionally you just wind up in a
situation where it's like oh you want to
lose weight at a modest clip cool you're
doing keto yeah yeah it really puts you
in a position where you don't have a lot
of flexibility
if you have a high body mass at the
start and you want to lose weight
relatively quickly
and if anyone is in a position to safely
have a relatively high rate of weight
loss it would be someone who has a
relatively high body mass at baseline of
course you don't want to get too carried
away with it but but that is an instance
where we can you know kind of move
things along more quickly and get that
momentum rolling so um one of the things
that that you run into is a bit of
especially with the fat recommendation
this kind of paradoxical situation where
if you compare uh someone with high body
mass with some some excess adiposity
they're trying to lose uh if you compare
someone in that scenario to like
you know a physique competitor let's say
in the bikini or figure division who
weighs 100 or 105 pounds you run into
this kind of paradoxical scenario where
the individual who really critically
needs to make sure they're being mindful
of of you know sufficient dietary fat on
a daily basis is getting a very low
recommendation and the person who isn't
in such a critical state where they need
you know that full
0.5 grams per kilogram of body mass
they're getting a much
a much more generous recommendation in
terms of daily uh dietary fat intake it
puts you in this paradoxical situation
where the priority is almost kind of
inverted so what we did to get around
that uh was we actually base our uh
lower limit for fat not the
recommendation this is important this is
like your absolute lower limit on a
daily basis that your your fat intake
should never get below
but we based that on height so we
basically said uh if you're over 150
centimeters tall
i'm violating my rule of freedom units
now going into centimeters but you take
your height in centimeters minus 150 you
divide that by two and you add 30. and
that many grams of fat is kind of the
lower limit that you really ought never
go below
now if you're under 150 centimeters tall
then just a flat value of 30 grams per
day would work as an absolute lower
limit that you're never going below so
when we scale it by height we don't run
into that situation where we have this
kind of paradoxical thing where the
people who really need to be mindful of
their their uh
dietary fat intake on a daily basis are
getting these excessively restrictive
numbers and the people who have a little
bit more wiggle room are getting these
really generous recommendations
so that's how we tackled fat which uh i
think is a kind of a creative way to do
it to be honest um it it differs from
the typical recommendation that's just
grams per kilogram of total body mass
and i think it's getting dietary fat
where it needs to go most effectively
yeah when it comes to protein
this is an area where we put a lot of
thought into it and with protein i think
in the evidence-based fitness world
we've gotten into that kind of knee-jerk
response protein 1.6 to 2.2 morton and
colleagues it's a meta-analysis
we trust yeah yeah we like that here it
is everybody use it and it's gotten to
the point that when you work with a
client no matter what their body
composition is like if you give a
protein target under 2.2 grams per
kilogram they're they like balk at it
there's this reaction of like
why am i not getting the lifter
recommendation you know under 1.6 you
mean
under 2.2 man because honestly
people see the top end of the 95 percent
confidence interval and they say like
yeah that's where i should be well and
that's not the confidence interval
either that was just kind of in the
paper they said ah 1.6 to 2.2 that's
pretty good we will get into the
confidence interval i i think it does
happen oh yeah okay yeah i was yeah it
does happen to be the top of the
confidence interval but the
recommendation they're providing is not
the confidence interval for for their
break point so
uh
but usually with lifters
it's the top half of the confidence
interval yeah yeah yeah the their recom
their recommendation is
the mean value up to the top of the 95
confidence interval correct yeah so with
lifters though if you tell if you tell
them protein 1.6 to 2.2 that's
immediately filtered that's 2.2 you know
what i mean no one's going ah let me see
if i can go a little bit lower there's
just this natural inclination to aim for
the higher end of the range so we're
talking a little bit about a confidence
interval it's from this uh meta-analysis
by morton and colleagues it's a great
paper i love the paper i cite it all the
time it's a very nice paper
with some really good researchers on it
so i don't want it to sound like we're
being overly critical of the paper but
one thing that is unavoidable is that
the interpretation of that 1.6 to 2.2
there are some assumptions built into it
uh that i don't think a lot of people
wrestle with on a regular basis when
they kind of give out that
recommendation yeah we're not being
critical of the paper we're being
critical of the
uh
universalizing
and unnuanced uh interpretation of the
paper that's that's pretty common yeah
yeah so it was more critical of the
application of the finding than the the
work that went into the finding i guess
yeah so what they did in in this
particular aspect of the paper this part
of the paper is they plotted all these
different data points of like what was
your total protein intake in the
intervention and what was your change in
fat free mass and what they're trying to
figure out is if you're someone who's
lifting during an intervention here
at what protein intake on a daily basis
do we
do we essentially maximize your gains in
fat free mass like at what level
the assumption is that eventually we're
going to have diminishing returns where
you're eating enough protein to fully
support your gains in fat free mass what
they're trying to do is identify that
break point where the returns really do
start to diminish and beyond that break
point there's really not a lot of
inherent value associated with
increasing your protein ever higher so
that's the general approach of what they
were doing in this particular part of
the meta-analysis that's been applied
really broadly a couple things to keep
in mind first of all
because of the studies that actually go
in to the meta-analysis
this is kind of applicable to someone
who has a generally average body fat
percentage
and it's within the context of people
who are lifting who are not in a calorie
like a big calorie deficit
so
already there are assumptions about
who's using this number and in what
context they're using that number
because
just like any other systematic reviewer
meta-analysis
there is a specific uh
there are specific criteria for study
inclusion and beyond
inclusion exclusion criteria
there are certain studies that have been
done in certain studies that have not
yet been done yeah so ultimately you can
only analyze the research that does
exist and not
uh make assumptions about the research
that could someday exist yeah and so
with that number 1.6 to 2.2 that's grams
per kilogram of total body mass it's
probably going to work pretty well if
you're a lifter and you have relatively
moderate body fat level relatively
average uh compared to the typical
resistance training study uh and you're
not in a huge calorie deficit like it
and you're trying to maximize fat free
mass that that number is probably going
to work pretty well so the one thing is
the assumptions about who is using this
this uh
recommendation and in what context the
other thing to keep in mind is like i
said they're trying to identify this
break point
and the break point occurred at 1.6
grams per kilogram of body mass per day
of protein intake but the 95 confidence
interval of that break point
spans from
1.03 to 2.2
which nearly spans the entirety of the
data on the x-axis i mean the lowest
intakes are down around point a little
over 0.8
the highest intakes are about
2.25
maybe 2.3 something like that so
what that means is it's not a criticism
of the data but it is a reflection that
this
uh
this break point this inflection point
at 1.6 that is often treated as being
universally true and quite precise in
terms of the way people discuss it it's
a relatively imprecise
estimate
and only applies to the context that
that relates to the data actually going
into the model so
that is a really long explanation of
saying why
we didn't just want to have the app say
oh yeah 1.6 to 2.2 and we probably are
going to get some people who are
familiar with you know the
evidence-based fitness
kind of rules and regulations they're
going to get their protein
recommendation from macro factor and say
whoa whoa whoa this doesn't fall between
1.6 and 2.2 like what's going on here i
haven't seen that yet but it's probably
gonna happen right
so what we tried to do here um
i tried to really build in
uh
the recommendations i i tried to build
in evidence from
i'd say probably
three or four primary sources so i tried
to do some back calculation based on the
morton data and say okay if we make some
assumptions about the body composition
of participants how can we scale this
range to
kilograms of fat free mass instead of
total body weight
because again we need this to be
universally applicable to people with a
wide range of body fat levels and a wide
range of total body mass
i also used
leaned on some evidence from a study by
a researcher named bandigan and
colleagues and i also used uh some of
the data from the systematic review that
helms did i kind of triangulated all
three of those
ran some calculations and got down to
some protein recommendations that we
were both really happy with when we
started putting in some test numbers and
seeing how it reacted it tended to
correspond really well with real world
experience and match those three data
sources simultaneously
uh pretty well
and so in macro factor your protein
intake that's recommended is going to be
influenced by a few different things you
put in it's going to be your fat free
mass it's going to be your energy status
whether you're in a surplus deficit or
maintenance uh the type of exercise
activity you're doing whether it's you
know no exercise cardio only or
something involving resistance training
and then also personal preference we ask
you like hey are you gonna be annoyed if
we give you
a protein intake that's a little lower
than you want you know you can opt into
saying actually like give me the highest
protein that you think is advisable you
know we let you choose uh your
preference in terms of whether you're
someone who prefers low protein kind of
in the middle or you know really high
protein
so all of those things go into the
recommendation and you could get a
recommendation if you're someone who's
sedentary not training
uh your weight stable so you're not in a
deficit moderate to high body fat
percentage
and you have a preference for lower
protein intake i don't think it's all
that crazy to recommend a protein intake
uh you know down around 1.25 grams per
kilogram of fat free mass again this is
someone who's not lifting who has a
preference for lower protein i don't
think that's too crazy a recommendation
on the higher end for someone who is uh
you know highly active someone's really
lean they have a preference for high
protein intake they're in a big calorie
deficit i mean
we're basically describing a bodybuilder
who's trying to get pretty shredded
right for them up to 3.1 grams per
kilogram of fat free mass can can
definitely make sense you know so
there's a broad range there for the
typical lifter i think somewhere in the
range of two to two point seven two two
to two point seven five grams per
kilogram of fat free mass not total mass
is generally going to put you in a
pretty good range uh but like i said in
macro factor you're going to see some
variability based on all those different
data
inputs related to the type of training
you're doing your energy status your fat
free mass and your personal preference
so yeah uh we put as you can probably
tell a pretty sickening amount of
thought
into uh how to make sure these are
scalable to a really broad range of
users so that it will
basically across the entire
uh spectrum of different types of
activities and different uh body fat
levels we wanted to make sure that these
recommendations are going to be
absolutely solid across that entire
spectrum
yeah just to re just to reiterate that
th this part of the app like so we um
like everyone had their
had their fingers in every like little
pie as far as the app went uh like we
all
had input on everything but but this
this part was definitely
uh the one where where trex carried most
of the load and i'd say you put what
like
about
about like two weeks of consistent work
into making sure that
um because so the thing here is like
uh if you've been kind of swimming in
the evidence-based waters for
i don't know six months
um
kind of like the average numbers are
probably just burned into your head yeah
uh and
you know if if the
typical person with a normal body comp
uh normal weight loss or weight gain
goals came to you they said give me
macros and i'm not going to tell you
anything about myself and my preferences
just give me
macros i should aim for that are
probably pretty decent like i think
anyone could do that and it would take
virtually no effort the the thing that
um
the thing that did take a lot of work
was considering
every potential edge case so um
you know what if you are
super shredded
and like maybe still trying to lose
weight
faster than we would recommend like
can we still give recommendations that
even if that might be a somewhat
unadvisable goal will be the best thing
for that goal you've chosen or like you
know if you are
if you do have a body composition that
is
uh considerably outside the realm of
uh the research that people would often
consider for making these types of
recommendations like can
can we adequately accommodate that so
there was
there was a ton of stress testing for
basically every potential edge case that
we could think of and every time we came
up with a new set of recommendations it
was a process of being like well okay
here's here's like
12 archetypes of people who are all very
different and have very different goals
and very different preferences and so
like
let's just let's just run the numbers
for everyone
and see if we feel good about all of
these recommendations and so you know
it's not like just a
matrix where
okay you have person are they gaining
weight losing weight uh and are they
lifting like you know you're not dealing
with two considerations we're talking
about like
i don't know probably considerations
across eight different axes and like
trying to figure trying to figure out uh
sets of targets and recommendations that
would
apply to
everyone that we could think of
um
and that was i mean that was a big lift
and i kept using uh
wii pronouns but i mean
to be fair that was mostly eric uh and
he's not gonna brag on himself but he
he put in a ton of work into making sure
that the recommendations macro factor
gave
would be
appropriate for
virtually everyone um
and uh yeah i'm
[Music]
very very impressed with with what he
came up with like
uh i i i think like probably 80 percent
of our users won't ever experience that
because they're yeah they're in
situations where just the normal
recommendations work just fine
um
but yeah like the the
10 20 of people who
like maybe aren't served particularly
well by those typical sets of
recommendations uh we
we've i said we again
eric put uh a ton of thought and effort
into
um
making sure that the recommendations we
gave
would
would apply really well uh even to to
edge cases
yeah well i i appreciate that and uh
yeah so far like you said it's the type
of effort that if you do it well it will
never be appreciated
you know like it's it only surfaces if
someone gets just bonkers macro targets
and they're like what the hell happened
here so it's kind of trying to plan for
all those different scenarios and make
sure and so far we haven't had any
issues where someone's like hey my
macros are totally crazy um we did have
one instance where someone got their
macros and then changed them because
they didn't like them and then change
them back because they're like actually
yeah that was better uh and there were
some extenuating circumstances there but
i still take credit for it and i told
them that the app knows their
preferences better than they do before
they even used it which
is not true but
i'll take it
uh so those are the the two things that
i think have potential for big impact
from that article um
because i think uh you know when people
would ask me previously before i had to
really
uh get my hands dirty with these
calculations that are more generalizable
to different uh body shapes and body
sizes
people would would ask for
recommendations ah 1.6 2.2 it'll be fine
and they say well what if i weigh you
know 410 pounds and i say well then
don't use those recommendations they
don't work anymore
and that's not where you want to be with
broad recommendations you know you want
them to be scalable
and applicable to uh to more more
scenarios than just like oh you're a 180
pound male who lifts and is 15 body fat
boy do i have a recommendation for you
you know so yeah uh
i think the the fat recommendation and
the protein recommendation
uh have some potential for
maybe widespread adoption um
in terms of giving people some some
guidance with their their diet
if you're interested in the article it
goes into far more than just hey here's
you know a really long article about
ideal protein intakes it goes into
uh
that would be a cool article it would be
a cool article um but it's a little more
broad than that we talk about
micronutrients
fiber hydration a lot of faqs about some
common dietary
approaches
and so i think like i said if you're
looking for
you know kind of a one-stop shop to get
a diet set up or somewhere where you can
direct somebody who uh doesn't have a
lot of previous nutritional knowledge i
think this is a hopefully
going to be a useful resource
now
i think it's probably time to play us
out here
and um this is a really important
segment to play us out this week usually
you come out you you come up with the
topic and it's usually some stupid
kitchen stuff nobody cares about
with uh oh by the way i saw a recipe for
keto lasagna oh no and
i think you owe me an apology because
this keto lasagna was just it was just
a stuffed pepper that's all it was
it had nothing to do
[Laughter]
you thought mine was bad this was
literally just like
have you tried doing a stuffed pepper
with uh you know beef and cheese and
just normal stuffed pepper stuff
it's basically lasagna
so that's so good so anyway this is
totally different this is something that
has come up on the podcast before
uh fat bear week is coming up i believe
it starts on the 29th of september if
memory serves but uh basically what you
want to do on the 29th then is go in
make sure you lock in to a macro factor
subscription because that's the second
to last day i think of our
of our launch sale so go and take care
of that macro factor subscription i
wouldn't miss that but you also don't
want to miss fat bear week because what
you can do is
choose your favorite bear and see if
they end up winning the competition it's
basically an annual thing where bears
need to get ready to hibernate it's what
they like to do and they get very chunky
and so as as fans of these majestic
beasts you can see who got the chunkiest
and vote on a winner i believe so i'm
personally pulling for 32 chunk
that is his name number included 32
chunk
is a large adult male with narrowly set
eyes and a prominent brow ridge uh even
at his leanest chunk carries pretty
substantial fat reserves especially on
his hind quarters that boy thick exactly
uh in the early summer he tends to shed
a lot of the fur around his shoulders
and neck
and this exposes numerous scars and
wounds so uh
32 chunk is uh quite thick but also i
mean he he's been in his share of
battles he's a tough guy
and uh you know he was first identified
in 2007
as an independent chunky looking two and
a half year old bear since then he's
gone on to become one of the largest
adults at brooks river
and due to his size and strength he is
at the top tier of the bear hierarchy
over there in that particular bear
community gives him great access to
mating opportunities and fishing spots
and he's not afraid to displace others
from the resources he wants so he's not
taking any bs from other bears but his
behavior is described as enigmatic so
he's been shown he's been showing a
tendency to wait patiently uh to just
kind of scavenge some leftover salmon
and he'll even play with other bears and
as we all know that's pretty uncommon
for a dominant bear who's at the top of
the hierarchy so when you look at 32
chunk you see a well-rounded bear with a
strong battle history but he's also down
to earth and he's a pillar in his
community you know he's top of the
hierarchy but he'll still mingle with
people lower on the hierarchy so
that's why i like 32 chunk and also
because uh
my girlfriend's cat i call it chunk
that's the cat's nickname so i think
it's really fitting i think 32 chunk
is in real life what like most jim bros
think they are
yeah they're like yeah if i become the
largest person here that will grant me
access to greater mating opportunities
uh i have a lot of scars from from my
battles uh with the iron of course
uh
but yeah ultimately like i do have like
a attractive enigmatic personality and
like i'm not like the other guys yeah
i'm not your typical meathead bear like
i'm pretty chill yeah and sure maybe i'm
still carrying a little extra fat on my
hind quarters but like by next by next
beach season like it's gonna be dialed
in yep
um yeah cool i i i feel like i i know
this guy uh
that 32 trunk is no longer a bear but
about 14 people who i know in real life
now you're pulling for someone else
though a very different bear yeah so i'm
pulling for 128 grazer uh
my
so one thing to note about
eric's bear which he chose and uh you're
not going to know this unless you go to
the bear week website is uh when you go
to the meet the bears page 32 chunk was
coincidentally the first bear you
encounter on the page so i'm i'm
thinking this might just be kind of like
a i love lamp scenario no eric just fell
in love with the first bear that he saw
um you know the jury's still out but
that's certainly a plausible hypothesis
and i
uh took the time and effort when
outlining uh this podcast episode to
scroll all the way down to the second
bear on the list
and that was
and that was a 128 grazer uh
grazer is a large adult female with
blonde fur a long straight muzzle and
conspicuously large blonde ears uh you
know those are those are all clearly
things that one would look for in a bear
uh
you know they say that bears with long
straight muzzles tend to tend to be the
best bears
this has now become a bear phrenology
podcast
um
during the late summer and fall her fur
is grizzled brown and she is often one
of the fattest bears to utilize brooks
river so
again we both picked a good track record
yeah you're strong contenders you know
this sport here is becoming chunky so
yeah the past
uh past indicators don't guarantee
future success any financial advisor
will tell you that but uh you know maybe
we're bandwagon fans for chunk and
grazer but uh you know we we think that
they
uh have have good chances to win i mean
come december give me tom brady you know
what i mean yeah for sure it is what it
is uh grazer was introduced to brooks
river as a young cub in 2005 since since
then she's become one bear cam's most
one of the bear cam's most recognizable
bears so she's
a bit of a social media sensation uh
an influencer if you will
uh but you know it's it goes beyond the
looks for her she's also very skilled uh
she can fish successfully in many
locations but in the early summer she
prefers the lip of brooks falls where
she's in a
skilled angler so you know not only uh
not only do the people love her for for
her video content she puts out uh but
she's also a great fisherwoman and
that's to be commended um grazer is more
cryptic than most and often chooses to
fish in areas of the river away from
bear cam so again not only does she
create absolute magic when she gets on
the bear cam
but she
she's not craving the limelight you know
she's
uh she doesn't do it because she feels
like she needs it she's she's ultimately
a private person and i i relate to that
uh grazer is one of the most defensive
mother bears at brooks river um
she often preemptively confronts and
attacks much larger bears including some
of the most
including some of the river's most
dominant adult males in order to ensure
her cubs are safe so i think i know
where chunk got those scars he yeah you
know walks up to the bear cam and says
you want to know how i got these scars
and then grazer comes up and says yeah i
[ __ ] you up boy
her defensiveness is risky yet provides
her with access to areas of brook falls
that many other mother bears won't
approach so she
she gets exclusive access to places and
and you get that when you're a star
during 2020 she's raising two spring
cubs who benefit from their mother's
boldness in the face of danger and
competition and that really brings it
home for me all of these excellent
things i've said about graser
she is able to accomplish uh while being
a strong single mom so uh
anyway uh good luck with that chunk pick
uh i respectfully disagree
and i'm pulling for 128 grazer i'm a
little bit nervous
that we potentially picked bears from
last year's competition
because
it's like
it says during 2020 she's raising
two spring cubs i feel like yeah that's
that's very possible
well
i assume they're still alive
yeah the national park service uh really
should have updated the website if
that's the case so shame on them but oh
well uh bear week it's happening be sure
to join in on the fun and we're we're
pulling for 32 chunk
uh all right
as always thanks so much for joining us
on the stronger by science podcast and
we will be back soon with another one